h
alle lieben freuen und herzlich
willkommen hier zu einer weiteren app
die ich heute mal wieder zog und zwar
bei cbc das ganze ist nämlich in die
einstellungen wir gehen nämlich mal
einfach auf play und zwar gehüpft dieser
typ hier und ich muss wenn ich drauf
clique haue ich denen einfach auf dem
boden das heißt es ein bisschen nice bin
dagegen gesprungen aber trotzdem was
bekommen als single ausgeben also das
unterscheidet sich so was wie soll ich
denn da durchkommen um ein gottes das
ist so ungewohnt dass man nicht
irgendwie man drückt nicht um zu
springen sondern man druckt drückt und
leser egal ob guck mal das eis
winterlandschaft soll jetzt wie denn das
wie soll das denn gehen weil ich mache
jetzt immer einfach so es ist doch nicht
wahr macht denn irgendwas verfällt und
gelogen ich wollte heute kein video
machen wo ich ausraste aber hier ist es
vorprogrammiert das ist doch das ist
auch so eine komische steuerung aber es
ist heiss co
manche kommen ja nicht mal so weit dass
ich irgendwie münzen bekommen um
irgendwie mal level hochzukommen
borrowed time on the floor we have to
jump jump und ich glaube das ist sogar
sofort das offen heißt es ist doch nicht
wahr
jetzt bin ich hier auch unserem in
seinem schloss drin oder meine erste
münze ja meine allerersten jüngste sorgt
den hab ich nicht gesehen ich dass eine
fackel gewesen oder irgendwas am rand
als erinnert natürlich ein bisschen an
wie so dreht sich denn schon wieder ist
erinnert ein sehr sehr stark an
minecraft wegen den blöcken und dem
ganzen steht ich denke mein gott ich bin
nämlich so ein bisschen an minecraft wir
den ganzen blöcken und so also denkt
jeden wird es direkt am main greift
erinnern aber es ist ein eigenständiges
spiel was nicht von mojang sondern was
als ob ich dieses level nicht
da mache ich irgendwas falsch liegen des
steuerungs änderung also es ist schon
richtig immer wenn ich rede ich brauche
doch nur 50 von den coens mein ziel war
es eigentlich in diesem video nicht
wirklich auszurasten
oh mein gott erschafft alles von alleine
gerade disketten war in diesem video
nicht ausrasten weil immer kommen alle
an das ist ja nur gespielt damals das zu
mir ausgehe weil ich da aber ich konnte
damals wenn die ausrasten weil meine
eltern mit mir gewohnt und jetzt monika
alleine eigentlich gedrückthalten
nebringen auch nichts ich versuche jetzt
mal bei allen sachen aber klar das ist
da wieder nicht geht freunde ich glaube
dass hier wird mein mann bin richtig
motiviert immer bei diesem wieso sind
dann ab diese drehen denn das kann auch
nicht sein
wie könnt ihr dann immer diese drehen
dinge hier soll das war ganz knapp jetzt
hier noch den das ding geholt hier
drunter her hielt man oh mein gott dem
skills krems jetzt neue heizkörper
trotzdem das kann doch nicht sein als ob
dieses spiel so fucking schwert ich
hab's im appstore gesehen und dachte mir
nur so war nein ich bin bei dem münze
darüber gesprochen dass im app store
gesehen und dachte mir wow das sieht
cool aus ist es zu minecraft so ein
bisschen auch mario mäßig und jump'n'run
und den ganzen schild kann er nicht
allzu schwer sein aber dieses spiel hat
mich eines besseren belehrt es gibt ich
möchte es nicht weiterspielen
wettringerin was es sieht aus wie simon
beginnen
hingehen sieht genauso aus wie simons
kindes ist nicht wahr als ob ich jetzt
mit dem mit dem screen hier schon zwei
davon eingesammelt sogar über muss doch
mal einmal so ein verdammt nur an hier
der jetzt mal endlich auch dann
vernünftig von mir zu ende geführt wird
mein gott und hier oben drüber
ich will so ungern dieses video beenden
wenn ich noch nichts hin geschissen habe
ich brauche einfach nur 50 von den
münzen und wahrscheinlich ist es sogar
das erste level aber es ist einfach so
fucking schwer
ich verstehe das gar nicht ich dachte
dieses spiel wäre echt oder so aber es
oder kapiere ich die steuerung einfach
nicht gibt es daheim trick oder so bei
ich meine ladet euch einfach mal runter
das heißt bauen sie so oder so irgendwie
im app store oder android keine ahnung
aber ich verstehe es nicht problem ist
halt einfach auch dass der so oft
einfach nicht reagiert das heißt ich
gerade die ganzheit und zwischendurch
springt er trotzdem einfach mal ein
bisschen früher nach unten oder ein
bisschen weiter nach oben oder was ich
aber ich glaube sie daran
immer wenn ich schon so richtig fertig
aus ich kann dieses spiel nicht besiegen
um ein gott franz jetzt nie der den
betten yu-na ihnen immer noch 77
ich wollte dieses video eigentlich nicht
so lange halten weil das spiel wieder
keinen sinn macht und ich immer in den
einstelligen analytics sehe dass ihr
immer sehr viel schneller abschaltet
wenn das spiel so total sinnfrei ist in
das spiel ist total sinnfrei unter zu
schaffen auch nicht mal ich hör auf